now it is lunch money time miss plana
how are you i'm great are you yeah
amazing don't look like spring
today it's summer whatever oh yeah wait
is this summer
oh yeah this summer wow
i don't know guys some people forget the
day of the week you forget what season
we're doing okay what's up all right so
the fed increased rates by 75 basis
points and then
jay powell jerome powell
wait who's jay powell same guy oh okay
i got confused
um he said that from the perspective of
today either a 50 basis point or 75
basis point increase seems most likely
at our next meeting in july but then he
went on to say
clearly today 75 basis point increase is
an unusually large one and i do not
expect moves of this size to be common
yet
next month it will be common
see i got a checking account and i got a
savings account i got a checking account
i got a savings account maybe i'll do
something maybe i won't maybe we'll do
50 basis points maybe we won't maybe do
75 maybe we won't maybe do 100 maybe do
25
it's all what they call a fugazi it's
what they're doing here at the end of
fugazi at the end of the day you don't
know what a fugazi is
i don't know what that is a fugazi you
can't say it like that yeah no fugazi
it's basically it's just like uh hey
look oh i gotta watch you wanna watch i
gotta watch watch you i got you watch it
like that's the game right it's just
like look here look here oh they put the
ball in the cop on the street like a
magician okay and like where's the ball
and you're like oh the ball's not even
there had that happen i don't know it's
an
illusion and that's what these people
are running they're running an illusion
because at the end of the day the
federal reserve they got no clue they
are not in control the federal reserve
is not in control of the economy what
the federal reserve is is they are
definitely in control of asset prices
they are tanking asset prices in an
attempt to control inflation but they
thought inflation was transitory then
they thought it was good for you then
they thought that it peaked and now all
of a sudden they're like oh [ __ ] we got
to keep hiking interest rates 75 basis
point hike is a very significant hike i
do agree with them there i don't know
what they're going to do in july neither
do they uh and i don't think that we
should likely see 75 basis point hikes
in a consistent basis moving forward but
i also kind of out of left field think
that they have near zero percent chance
to continue to hike rates at the way
that they are talking now they will wave
the white flag at some point they will
give up they will say oh damn we can't
keep doing this the question is when do
they do that how severe is the
reflexivity of the interest rates back
and when will the first interest rate
cut be
i think
that it for if i had a base case it'd be
20 23
but i think that there is a higher
probability than most people realize
that we get an interest rate cut before
the end of the year an interest rate one
last thing i will say
is that they're talking top they're out
there beating their chests hey we're
gonna we're gonna be tough we're gonna
be like paul volcker i don't know if you
know who paul volcker is in the 1970s
he raised interest rates that's like 20
to attack inflation spelled
v-o-e-l-c-k-e-r
no
v-o-l-c-k-e-r uh but
listen i don't know how to spell but i
know how to spell the guys you say you
put an e in there somewhere where there
went there's a there's an e look it up
and so if all of a sudden yeah
wait hold on
paul you said paul bunker yeah paul no
jim jim voelker who's jim voelker i
don't know it's his evil twin brother
there's no eve but i could swear there's
no e wait it's what does that mean you
are not wrong i'm not wrong that's fine
not wrong and right or too the same so
one of the key things is they're going
to keep talking very very tough we're
going to be like paul volcker we're
going to hike interest rates we're going
to take on inflation we're in control
all this stuff
no they're not
no they are not what are they gonna do
high kids rates at twenty percent
they'll literally crash the global
economy and people will die like there's
no way that they can do that so at the
end of the day what is likely going to
happen
is that they are going to try to talk
tough try to talk tough try to talk
tough and some point
it all breaks and when it breaks they
going right back in the other direction
because we have to have the loose
monetary policy nick carter was on the
show yesterday he was talking about
listen they could have done 20 base 20
back in the 70s because uh global debt
to gdp or the american debt to gdp was
so much lower there's all these things
right now people are already hurting the
economy was already contracting in q1
these people are hiking interest rates
going into a recession it's insanity it
is literally insane and so i don't think
they'll be successful in doing this over
time all right well
volcker without the e
who am i thinking of okay millennial
millionaires
because now millennials are millionaires
are they they're now getting up into the
millionaire class yeah yeah shout out to
you guys temporarily shelving major
purchases as intern interest rates and
inflation rise so it says that nearly
half of millennial millionaires say
higher borrowing costs are causing them
to delay buying a car and 44 say higher
interest rates have caused them to delay
purchasing a home so just this is the
part where i just my head is in a
blender my head don't go in a blender
very often the nbc is a millionaire
survey but my head is in a blender well
because what you just said and what the
headline says are two completely
different things pull up that headline
again please the headline specifically
says that they oh no not this one go
back one uh what the headline says is
that the millennial millionaires are
delaying home and car purchases due to
inflation
inflation is what they're saying now you
read again what the article says that
higher borrowing costs and then higher
interest rates so they say due to
inflation in the title but it says
interest rates in the article i don't
the reason is not because of inflation
it's definitely because of the interest
rates now they are interrelated to some
degree
but at the end of the day
interest rates are why people are not
buying houses is because the cost of
capital has exploded and if you can't
borrow the money then they're not going
to buy the house the cost of the home
doesn't matter if you get free cash to
buy it that's the part that
nobody tells uh non-rich people
the cost of the home does not matter if
you have access to free money yeah right
if somebody says hey there's a 10
million home it's like wow that sounds
crazy okay and the interest rate is zero
right right we're just gonna give you a
cash and you never have to pay it back
well you can go buy a ten million dollar
house like if they'll loan you ten
million dollars right but what ends up
happening is that when interest rates
are super super low again it's an
egregious example but like when interest
rates are really low people are willing
to borrow a bunch and go buy houses and
if you're able to borrow more that means
you're willing to bid more and the home
prices all explode upwards but when they
now raise interest rates people can't
borrow as much money because they can't
actually service the debt and therefore
it cools off demand we're already seeing
this today u.s house starts
is another great one for you
they estimated the forecast i think was
minus 1.8 percent that was the forecast
guess what the number is that it came in
at
estimated minus 1.4 or 1.8 percent guess
what the number came in
2.1
negative 14.4 percent
like you could have asked jacob the 11
year old that was on the show the other
day make up a number and he might have
been closer that's how crazy it is
all right what's up with the campaign um
also i'm not interested i don't care
about millennial millionaires like how
is this affecting like regular people
who the hell cares about millennial
millionaires sorry okay
crypto fundraising this is interesting
a new startup called tilt sorry called
engage raise that's what it's called
is going to allow federal candidates to
raise campaign cash solely through
crypto
interesting and crypto executives have
contributed more than 30 million dollars
towards federal candidates and campaigns
since the shop uh i can't talk to you
you want to be a savage you want me to
just uh just to be nice today what this
doesn't matter why next why doesn't it
matter
because any payment any payment company
can do this what do you mean it's a
payment company you can accept donations
guess what you could accept any donation
you set up a bitcoin wallet you can
accept donations like
so why is there a company dedicated to
it well i'm assuming because somebody
said we could make it easier we could do
better tracking of the financials like
all this stuff but like at the end of
the day like
whatever
it's just i just don't think that this i
do think it matters because it brings it
into the
into the conversation right so now like
these political candidates are like oh
look there's a platform specifically for
this and i don't have to send my sketchy
wallet address to people to send me
money
i don't think most people are giving
their bitcoin or crypto to politicians
if you ain't willing to sell it to the
bankers you're definitely not giving it
to the politicians people might
not be the most politically minded
people i bet you very small percentage
of all donations in the united states
are crypto related because what happens
is people may want to support a
candidate because of their stance to say
on bitcoin if you're like hey i'm a
single issue voter and you're pro
bitcoin i want to support you but i'm
gonna give you dollars why would i'm not
gonna give you my my bitcoin like huh
joke's on you i'll give you fiat
not bitcoin okay all right you don't
think so
i don't know all right
what's up all right so this one's
interesting youtube announced today that
it's rival service youtube shorts i
think it's rivaling tiktok um has been
is being watched by over 1.5 billion
logged in users every month
less than two years after its launch
so hold on a second listen to it hey
boys we gotta get on the shorts game
less than two years i thought it just
launched
no they've been testing it oh really
yeah that's a big number though it's a
big number you know what that shows
people are watching shorts on youtube
yeah yes that is uh you're not wrong
is uh first-time entrepreneurs worry
about products second time entrepreneurs
worry about distribution youtube has
distribution doesn't matter if they got
a copycat product doesn't matter if it's
their own version doesn't matter if
products good or not they got a lot of
users
that i like youtube's version versus
just tick tock is that like you may
watch a short and then be led into a
more long-form video or conversation if
you're interested and tick-tock you
watch 10 seconds you're like well
there's not more where this came from so
i agree i think that you listen i've
said this for a long time uh instagram i
think pretty much showed it like
instagram has uh uh with reels uh with
disappearing content of the stories like
all this stuff i mean distribution
matters it matters a ton and it's really
hard to compete with these big companies
who have that distribution so i think
people need to continue to wrap their
heads around products and innovation
only matter if they get adopted but if
somebody else looks over and says oh
that's a great idea guess what we got
two billion people but do you remember
how everybody thought that instagram
stories would be the snapchat killer and
it wasn't and i think that it just
people found a different use for it
like
when i asked my little sister she was
like oh like instagram stories is where
like people are more presentable and
more professional and then snapchat is
where you actually send like whatever
you're sending i don't know
right
maybe what's bulldog t-rex
all right
so um so people said of mine wins or not
is very nice i don't know yeah that's
really does a really great one is that a
windsor knight is that what it's called
you do a great one yeah i just call that
the ball snot
if you see double windsor yeah if you
see somebody rocking a one like that
they gotta have spent some time on it
for sure guaranteed
my dad i'm a one-shot shooter though my
dad would always like be like ugh those
men who have the crinkle wrinkle
whatever here in the tide those aren't
real men i'm like what's that
i've never seen a guy tie a tie a tie
and he's got like a little it looks like
like like you can't even tell the
difference between the tie and the knot
and then it's kind of like sideways or
whatever and you look at it you're like
bro it's not like smooth but i think
that's a style if you're seriously
wearing the suit and tie to work or
whatever like take some pride let's go
i'm wearing it just because i'm doing my
duty to fight the bear market i got
shorts on under here so just so
everyone's clear right this is like a
little bear market costume but if i
really wore it to work
i'll be seeing some windsor knots
that would make windsor castle
jealous
you know i knew windsor castle did you
you guys you didn't know i knew windsor
castle did not know yeah i know about
that place who lives at windsor castle
important people
if it's a castle must be a king or a
queen right
is it yes ah
is it in europe
of course is it in the uk oh wait does
the queen live there
i'm not dumb
you guys today what is today i'm not
dumb
windsor castle
i know about all the queen stuff all
right did you know that the queen gets a
dollar per head from australia i told
you that from every ticket every year
yes but every single yeah out here
literally getting taxes off people that
don't even know who she is
that's crazy uh people are saying uk is
not in europe
what
it's like its own weird thing remember
kind of brexit okay uh
all right let's go so
archaeologists that by the way if that's
the hill that people are going to die on
is is the uk in the europe or not i'm
out the bulldog face dinosaur so they
found this bone that led to them
believing this uh
this this thing existed
a bulldog is a dinosaur look at the
little arms yeah listen it's it's this
is a bird with legs they call it a t-rex
on steroids it used to be
listen is that tara do you understand
the leap of faith like the chinese are
saying that they got this big ass
satellite that they think they have uh
received a message from an alien
civilization
do you understand the leap of faith it
takes to find a bone in the ground and
come up with that uh uh image
how do you find one bone you're like oh
let's just draw him with a big ass tail
they did say that they said single bone
one single bone and they've got his arms
looking like that and they were i'm
disrespecting that man
put some respect on his body
what's this body shaming going on at
dinosaurs
this is crazy talk all i hear body shame
in these animals what do you think he
actually looks like i'm not here to
judge hey whatever the dinosaurs look
like i'm sure he was happy
why y'all why y'all out here do you find
one bone in the ground next you know
you're drawn cartoons don't body shame
dinosaurs yeah i mean this is crazy talk
so uh before i get to something that
will absolutely change everybody's life
forever
i this is a surprise but i was thinking
about it while we were talking but
before then
people are asking do you have some hope
for the people
in this kind of bear market
listen
at the end of the day a bear market is
literally it's a slingshot that's
ultimately what it ends up being in 2018
bitcoin's price went from uh 20 000 to 3
200 whatever it went down 85
and if you're sitting you're like damn
down 85 well guess what happened over
the next three years went up 20 x
it's literally bear markets are
slingshots now you don't know where the
bear market ends you don't know exactly
what's going to be the assets that end
up working but across stocks bonds real
estate crypto the whole thing
bear markets are slingshots and guess
what follows bear markets assets that
are good good assets hit all-time highs
it may take
six months it may take six years it
could take 20 years dang
usually it takes shorter rather than
longer
but bear markets are slingshots
for the most part
for good assets i mean if you got a bad
asset right like like take crypto for
example bitcoin the bear market in my
opinion will absolutely be a slingshot
and we will see another bitcoin all-time
high basically what you have to ask the
bears is do you believe bitcoin will hit
another all-time high and if they say no
laugh
if they say yes then are they really
bears
right then on top of that
many of the altcoins that are down 90 95
99
it's over see ya y'all might as well
just hold a funeral game over
we'll see what happens we'll see that's
how game gets played this is not
financial advice by any stretch
correct are you trying to change the
subject from people body shaming the
dinosaurs
so people are saying that you're awoke
because you're not into body shaming the
dinosaur hey louie i i'm so woke that's
great all right
okay ready for my mind-blowing
fact yeah so i've you know i've been
thinking a lot about this actually why
do we call it a bear and bull market do
you know
a what why do you call it a bear market
in a boat where did where did it get its
name i don't know tell me no but do you
know no
something he doesn't know well you
didn't know either you looked it up on
the super computer because i use my tool
and knowledge okay so
are you sure you know where the page
is so it comes from the way in which
each animal attacks its opponents it's
prey so a bull will thrust its horns
into the air while a bear will swipe
down
is that fascinating
that is absolutely mind-blowing please
tell me bears are sleeping bulls are
charging yes julia
that's that's really why it is that's
what it says
what a source investopedia
um i'm uh i'm gonna hold anything but by
the way tomorrow see bear attacks down
people know can we can tomorrow can we
please talk about the chinese satellite
that they think they found an alien
civilization there is no
no they they listen that's what they're
saying
they said a lot of things over the last
two years
the chinese
there's a lot of things over the last
two years you got to take everything
with a grain of salt but they do claim
that they have a big ass satellite i saw
a photo of a satellite that they claim
is theirs uh and they claim they
received a message which they claim also
uh
alien civilization i only spew facts he
spews claims am i free to go see ya
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time